تقول ان العالم يراقب ازمه المنطاد عن
كثبوا رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه الصيني
يقول ايضا ان بعض الاطراف لا تريد الحل
السلميه للازمه الاوكرانيه ويقول ايضا يجب
ان لا نخوض حربا نوويه ولسنا جزءا من
الازمه في اوكرانيا لكننا لن نبقى مكتوب
فيه الايدي واضاف ان الحرب في اوكرانيا
ليس ما نود رؤيته نذكر مره اخرى
للمشاهدينا بما قاله رئيس لجنه الشؤون
الخارجيه الصينيه قال ان العالم يراقب
ازمه المنطاد عن كثب ويقول في هذه اللحظات
ايضا ويتحدث عن ان بعض الاطراف لا تريد
الحل السلميه للازمه الاوكرانيه والعالم
يراقب ازمه المطاعم كثف كما يظهر على
الشاشه الان ويجب ان لا نخوض حرباويه
ويقول ايضا
رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه الصينيه ضمن
اعمال مؤتمر ميونخ الذي يجري الان
لسنا جزءا من الازمه في اوكرانيا لكننا لن
نبقى مكتوب في الايدي
ويتحدث ايضا رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
الصينيه ويقول ان الحرب في اوكرانيا ليس
ما نود رؤيته ونذكر المشاهدين بان هذا
الحديث لرئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
الصينيه ياتي ضمن اعمالهم مؤتمر ميونخ
الذي بدا يوم امس انعقد منذ يوم امس اليوم
الاول ويستمر لمده ثلاثه ايام
معكم في متابعه هذه الكلمه الان لوزير
الشؤون الخارجيه الصينيه
للاستغلال الولايات المتحده
كانت دائما تبتز
مصالح من
ونامل ان
يحاول ايجاد قنوات تواصل بحيث تكون حياديه
وعادله
وهناك تقدم في الانسانيه لا اعرف لماذا
الولايات المتحده توقف هذا التقدم نامل ان
يفكر الجانب الامريكي باتخاذ
خطوات
تفاعلي اكثر ايجابيه تجاه الصين هذه
مسائل تفيد المجتمع الدولي ناهيك عن
بلدينا ايضا
هذا الحوار سيستكمل
ربما لدينا دقيقه بالتطمين الحضور على ان
تصيد العسكري حول تايوان ليس وشيك هل لك
ان تطمئن الحضور
باختصارتها وتطمئن الحضور ان هي جزء من
الارض الصينيه لم تكن دوله
ولن تكون دوله في المستقبل ايضا هذا هو
الوضع الراهن للقضيه التايوانيه
فليست الصين الصين التي تغير الوضع الراهن
بل قوات الانفصاليه التايوانيه على
الجزيره
ان القوات التايوانيه
تقود السلام والاستقرار اعني هنا بالقوات
الانفصاليه التايوانيه هذا امر لا بد من
اجماع المجتمع الدولي عليه فنحن نؤكد على
اهميه
احترام سياده الدول فهذه ايضا للصين يجب
ان تطبق
القوات الانفصاليه التايوانيه تهدد سياده
الصين لا نريد ان يكون هناك ازدواجيه
بالمعايير حول هذه القضيه شكرا لكم
مشاهدينا كنا معكم في متابعه لهذا الجزء
من كلمه السيد وانجلي كبيره دبلوماسيين
الصينيين وذلك ضمن اعمال مؤتمر ميونخ
للامن الذي انطلق يوم امس الجمعه في دورته
التاسع والخمسين وقال الان ان نظره واشنطن
لبكين خاطئه جدا والعالم بازمه المنطاد عن
كثب ويجب عدم خوض اي حرب نوويه تحت اي ظرف
واضاف ايضا ان بعض الاطراف لا تريد الحل
السلمي للازمه الاوكرانيه ويجب ان لا نخوض
حرباويه ولسنا جزءا من الازمه في اوكرانيا
لكننا لن نبقى مكتوب في الايدي